por aire tierra o mar el transporte se
detiene en Grecia conductores de trenes
barcos aviones y del transporte público
de las principales ciudades apagaron el
motor de sus vehículos para protestar
por el accidente más grave del país en
el que murieron 57 personas el pasado 28
de febrero el accidente se dio entre un
tren de 350 pasajeros y un tren de carga
ambos colisionaron de frente en la
región central griega de tempi cerca de
larisa
tras el suceso los trabajadores han
denunciado la falta de inversión pública
y la deficiencia de las medidas de
seguridad en el ferrocarril griego la me
creo que las medidas deberían haberse
tomado hace mucho tiempo y no deberían
estar esperando a que sucediera un
accidente para tomarlas de igual manera
sean cual sean las medidas no aplacarán
el dolor del pueblo
en la huelga de hoy que se espera sea de
24 horas y que llegó hasta inmediaciones
del parlamento fue convocada por los
sindicatos más grandes del sector
público y privado la gente está muy
enojada pero tampoco saben qué hacer no
podemos cambiar repentinamente a todos
los políticos Entonces qué podemos hacer
la gente no sabe la gente está muy
triste ni siquiera sabemos Qué hacer en
las próximas elecciones no sabemos qué
hacer una vez frente al parlamento las
manifestaciones estallaron en
enfrentamientos con la policía con gases
lacrimógenos piedras y bombas Molotov
la semana pasada miles de personas
salieron a las calles en lo que fue una
de las mayores protestas contra el
gobierno que asumió en 2019 el Primer
Ministro críacos mitsutakis cuyo mandato
finaliza en julio Se disculpó
públicamente por el accidente y prometió
modernizar las líneas e impulsar la mano
de obra en el sector ferroviario